(slow music)
If the person who made it says it's art, then it's art.
So, it's all about the intention.
Artists are people who make things for other people.
Art communicates things that everything else
fails short to do.
(slow music continues)
Art is my North Star.
Today, we're gonna talk about art,
how to define it,
how to understand it, and why it matters.
My conversational partner for this affair
is Heidi Zuckerman,
a global authority on contemporary art
and a woman I've known for over 30 years.
Heidi is the former CEO and director
of the Aspen Art Museum,
which she successfully reimagined
as a world-class institution,
and she's currently the CEO and director
of the Orange County Museum of Art.
Prior to both, she held posts at Berkeley Art Museum
and Pacific Film Archive and was a curator
of the Jewish Museum in New York.
In addition to curating literally hundreds
of exhibitions over the years,
Heidi also hosts the podcast
"Conversations About Art" and is the author
of the "Conversations With Artists" book series.
This one's a little bit different from my usual affair,
but very special, I think,
as Heidi is a very special person.
I really enjoy talking to her, and I hope you dig it.
So, please hit that Subscribe button and enjoy.
(soft music continues)
I can't believe you're here.
(chuckles) Me neither.
The more I think about, like, the tapestry of our lives
and how they've overlapped at certain weird stages
over the years, like the more surreal it is.
It's pretty wild to like sit across from you
with all of this weird history.
And I feel the same.
You know, I just got back from Dallas and had
my YPO forum there.
We spent the day with Rand Stagen,
and I kind of track getting back in touch with you to him,
and so many things in my life kind of come from him.
So, yeah, I agree.
Yeah, I was just in Miami and did a YPO event there.
I'm sure.
I, like, hosted
this whole, like, conference recently.
We'll talk about the YPO stuff.
Okay.
But I mean, going way back,
just for people that are watching or listening,
we met, I think it was '91, around that time,
maybe '92, something like that.
I was dating your sister, Laura,
and I got quite close with your whole family.
Like, I've been to your house in Huntington
and, like-
Which is gone.
I know, yeah, I know.
(Heidi laughing)
I know Gary and your mom.
How are they, are they good?
Yeah, so we just got back
from celebrating Gary's 70th birthday-
Wow.
In London,
and, well, you know, my mom
had not gone on a plane across the ocean
in a really long time.
She wanted everyone to come to their lake house
to celebrate his birthday, and I said,
"I can't on March 24th, I'm gonna be in London,
visiting Emerson," and I said, "you guys should come.
We should celebrate his birthday there,"
and they picked up what I put down,
and it kind of was a life-changing moment for them.
So, I can tell you a little bit more about it,
but it was great.
Yeah, it's so interesting.
I mean, I have like a lot of very kind of vivid flashes
from that period of time, you know, little weird memories,
but I think you were working at a gallery downtown,
if memory serves me, around that era.
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, I started at the Jewish Museum in 1993.
It was before that, yeah.
Yeah, so I had a couple
of different jobs, like Stux Gallery and for Anne Levay.
So, yeah, '91, '92.
Right.
Yeah.
And Laura was doing acting,
and I remember going to a site-specific theater performance
that was in like an abandoned house.
Like in the meat packing district?
I think so, well, that was a different one.
I remember that one, too.
Okay, that one was great.
And she was working with Darren Aronofsky
and had worked on "Pi" and "Requiem for a Dream".
Yes.
It was just a really cool time to be in New York.
I feel like it was a moment where New York
was still very dynamic, but you could feel
that that was not gonna persist much longer.
It was definitely edgy,
and, you know, the intersection
between what Laura was doing,
which started out as theater 'cause she had been at NYU,
but it was really veering into performance art,
and it was kind of a time in the art world before people,
I mean, of course, there was performance art in the '70s,
but what she was doing really kind of predated
a lot of the self-focused work that came after that.
And now she's married
and lives in Copenhagen?
Yes.
Yeah, has kids and stuff like that.
Is she good?
She's good, too.
I'm glad to hear that.
They were all in London, and we did this thing.
I suggested it, and some people were more comfortable
and other people were less comfortable,
but the idea was to go around the table
and everyone to say something that they love about Gary,
and to use that language, and then, when we got to Gary,
whose birthday it was, he had to say something
that he loved about himself.
And Mike, my brother, went first, and then Laura went,
and I don't know if they used love.
I think they said, you know, like, one of the things I like,
and then Laura's older son said,
"You know, one of the things I love about Gary,"
and it just kind of changed the whole tone,
and it was very moving.
Yeah, that's sweet.
That's cool.
That phase of our lives was only the beginning
because we've crisscrossed.
We have lots of mutual friends in common
that come from very distinct and dissimilar places.
Just the other day I was with Rickey Gates.
Oh, yeah.
He's in the middle
of doing this thing that's called Ultra Training.
Do you know about this?
I don't think so.
So, this is his latest project,
which is taking an Amtrak train.
He left his home in Santa Fe,
and he's just getting off at every stop and running around
and doing this sort of a truncated run every street thing
at every stop along the way, and he came through LA.
So, I went down to Downtown Los Angeles.
I have a back problem right now, so I can't really run,
and I was like, "I'll come and meet you,
but we're gonna have to walk," and we just ended up walking
all around the Arts District and talking,
and he's filming it for a documentary project.
And, of course, your name came up
because it's so bizarre that, like, you're friends
with Rickey Gates because of the Aspen thing.
Yeah.
And, you know, how he presents himself,
at the intersection of, like, art and athleticism.
Yes.
Like, he is an artist.
And everything he does
is some amalgam
of performance art
and kind of ephemera,
like running around is something
you can't really capture unless you're filming it,
and that becomes these projects with photography and film
and his writing and all of that.
Like, he's a very unique guy in that regard,
but we had a very fond conversation about you.
Thank you, and did he tell you about the Hut Run Hut?
He did, yes.
Yeah.
So, explain that.
The idea is that you're gonna curate
one of his Hut Run Hut expeditions
and have artists, like, in residence to kind of share
at the end of the day of running around.
Yeah, artists and athletes.
Yeah.
And so, I'm really interested in this idea of a practice,
and it comes from, you know, Buddhism, right,
and this idea of like a life practice.
And it started for me as like a curatorial practice,
and then, you know, a life practice,
and then this idea of, you know, who practices.
So, artists practice and athletes practice,
and of course, musicians practice, too,
but you know, what does that mean?
So, it's like you do something repeatedly,
and then you can get better at it,
but also, you know, there's variety to it.
Some days you're stronger, some days you're tired,
some days you, you know,
are bursting with energy and ideas,
and other days, like, you have nothing, right?
And so, Rickey and I started talking about that
and how it would be really interesting,
'cause I'm also fascinated with this idea
of kind of pushing the limits,
which I know you are, too.
Right.
So, what's that point of like stretching people
to, like, being uncomfortable,
but not, like, unbearably uncomfortable?
And so, this endurance idea of, you know, running,
or trail hiking, you know, probably,
like, it doesn't have to be a run, you know, motion
for five days and five nights,
a hundred miles over five days at altitude,
and to invite, I think it can be 12 people total,
so, you know, six artists and six athletes,
and have everyone have that shared experience.
And at the end of the day, of course, coming together
and talking about, you know, what it feels like to do that.
So, I've sort of been training,
and I asked him how to train,
and he's notorious for, like, not training.
Yeah. (laughs)
He's like,
"Just like go for an hour each Sunday,
and then add an hour," you know?
When is this happening?
So, we're gonna do it in,
I think, August of '23, yeah.
Next year, yeah.
We were going to do it this year, and then when I took
the job at the Orange County Museum of Art,
I'm not good at saying no.
Too much going on.
And I said, "Look, even for me,
to do this hundred mile thing
a month before we open the museum
is, like, not practical."
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, he said, "That's fine, we'll push it to 2023,"
but I'm sure you're on the list.
Yeah, like, he's like,
"Will you do it," and I was like, "Yeah."
I didn't know when it was, but I was like,
that sounds cool and unique, for sure.
Are we gonna sleep in that crazy bus thing?
No, we're gonna stay in these huts.
So, there's like a hut system,
like the 10th Mountain Division had these huts at altitude.
But this is the original idea behind this.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, all right.
Well, that'll be cool.
We're putting together
the list, yeah.
Yeah, who else is,
who, what other-
Lance said yes, too.
Oh, cool.
Yeah.
Who were the artists that you're thinking about for this?
So, I have a couple of ideas,
and, oh, I also asked Gretchen Bleiler,
and she's actually the one that introduced me to Rickey,
and so she's a yes, too.
Yeah, cool.
So, the athletes are easier-
She's a badass, yeah.
Than the artists, yeah.
She's a total badass
and a really, really close friend of mine.
So, I don't have any of the artists committed yet,
but I've tested it on a few people,
but we can use this conversation
to, you know?
Yeah.
And part of it was, for me,
you know, when he asked me about it,
I said I really only feel like I can say yes if I go,
and I talked to him about it a lot,
and I talked to Gretchen about it,
'cause at first I said, you know,
"I don't think I can do this,"
and interestingly, two days ago, I had this conversation.
So, I just did the Orange County Half Marathon.
I've never done anything
like that before.
Oh, congrats.
Well, then, you could do Hut Run Hut.
Well, yes.
After I did that, I do think that I can,
but it was kind of a mental thing.
And so, on Friday, when it was on Sunday, I texted a friend.
I said, "Do you want to do this?"
She said, "Yes," and we signed up, so, like, no training,
but I mean, I spent a lot of time on the trails.
Anyway, I was happy with myself, that I did it,
and I was saying to my boyfriend, you know,
like, "I'm just not physically brave."
I said, "I'm intellectually fierce,
but not physically brave," and he's like,
"What are you talking about?"
He's like, "You ride a bike around London.
You did this, you know, Half Marathon.
You, you know, kayak across these things,
and you know, what's your definition,
like, what's the threshold?"
And I think, because I know all of these,
like, incredible athletes and extreme athletes,
you know, my perception of myself
is not that.
Well, can I suggest
a bit of a reframe on it?
Yes.
Rather than thinking about it as something
that requires you being physically brave,
maybe just think about curiosity instead
because you're a very curious person,
so it's just a different lens for that curiosity.
It doesn't necessarily require braveness,
but it does require inquisitiveness,
like, hmm, I wonder what that would be like,
to have that experience?
Yeah.
Hmm, oh, I feel a little bit of fear.
That's interesting, I wonder what that's about.
Do I need to be afraid of this, you know?
And I think that, like, placates a lot of that anxiety.
Yeah, that's-
And if you've run
a Half Marathon, there's nothing really to fear.
Like, you'll be fine.
Well, run-walk.
Well, fine, but that's what, (chuckles)
I mean, look, the thing with Rickey isn't gonna be
a race, right?
No, no, not at all,
and the idea is to have that shared experience
and be, yes, you're right, curious about it and, you know,
get to pair up with different people at different points.
Yeah, yeah.
So, yeah, it's not a race.
Yeah, cool.
Well, let's talk about art.
I mean, first, let's just walk through,
like, you've had this robust history and many different,
you know, interesting positions in the art world.
I mean, you're a badass in the art world now.
You're like, I mean, it's crazy,
the influence that you wield in this very interesting world,
but what got you interested in art from the beginning?
When I was growing up,
I have this story that I tell.
You never met our grandmother, our father's mother.
Her name was Blanche, and she decided,
at a young age, that I would collect paper weights
and that Laura would collect boxes.
And so, every year, for our birthdays, you know,
instead of a dress or a doll, you know,
she would get a box and I would get these paper weights.
And so, you know, that idea of being around art objects
and kind of owning things
and having them in your space
is something that I can't ever remember not doing
or having or being.
And I really put it all back to her,
because I was the oldest grandchild,
our grandfather didn't like to travel,
and so from the time that I was about eight,
she would take me with her.
And she, you know, classic American story, you know,
born in America, first generation,
Lower East Side of New York.
They're furriers, she's allergic to mink.
She gets sent to an orphanage at age eight,
third grade education, and then, in marrying my grandfather,
who was from a wealthy Canadian family,
she started buying real estate in New York,
and she'd buy the apartments with everything in them,
and that's how she started to collect art.
And when she would run out of space,
she would send things to our house,
and so our house was filled with, you know,
fine and decorative arts.
You know, all the furniture came from my grandmother,
the rugs, the paintings,
and my parents were not interested in any of it.
It was like decor, but I was interested.
I can't really remember a time
that I wasn't interested in it,
but I never thought I would pursue it as a career.
I thought I would be, I thought I'd go to law school,
and I wanted to be a judge from the time I was a kid,
and I have a burning of the boats moment,
like Joseph Campbell style, that I can share.
Yeah,, what was that crossroads?
So, I was
in my,
I guess, junior year at Penn,
and I had had some kind of art experiences.
The summer after my freshman year, I came home,
looked in the phone book,
saw art galleries, called everyone,
lied, said that I was an art history student,
you know, looked for a job.
Got a job in an art gallery,
did my first studio visit with an artist named Sam Francis.
This was in the Bay Area?
Yeah, Palo Alto.
Palo Alto, and you know,
second-generation abstract expressionist,
really, really important artist.
His kids were around, you know, my, our age.
Hung out with them and went back to school,
got a work-study job at the ICA,
Institute of Contemporary Arts in Philadelphia,
met Mary Boone, David Salle,
these things that now sound like really big,
important things, but they were just the path,
right, without even any kind of reality
or cognizance around it.
And then, I mean, a friend of mine,
a guy by the name of Jonathan Guinness, who's an architect,
told me that there was this program
at Christie's auction house.
He said, "You seem to like art,
you know, like you seem to talk about it,"
and again, I wasn't aware of it.
I didn't have any awareness of it.
And he said, you know, "There's a program,
it's three months or four months in New York,
four months in Paris, four months in London.
You know, maybe you would like to do that."
And I had just, again, never thought of that
as a possibility and told my parents I wanted to pursue
a career in art and I wasn't gonna take the LSATs, you know,
and they were like, "What?"
Like, (laughs) "That's a terrible idea!
No one can make money in the art world,
that's not a career,"
but I got into the Christie's program.
I took the train to New York, I did the interview.
It was hard and scary and strange,
but I guess I did a good job,
and my grandmother said she would pay for me for the year.
Yeah.
So, I left for London,
and actually, Laura came.
She was doing
her junior year abroad,
and so we lived together for a semester in London.
So, that predates, I guess, probably right before
you guys met.
Right, so on some level,
it's sort of the equivalent of like getting a job
in the mail room at CA or something like that.
It's like an entry level internship,
but it gives you exposure to so many facets
of what this world is all about.
Yeah.
Yes, and, you know, I've heard you say,
you know, success looks like it happened overnight,
but it's like years of, like, grinding through, you know,
all sorts of uncomfortable situations,
and I guess that I have
the self-reflexivity at this point, you know,
to be able to look back and say, yeah,
I can draw a line through it.
Right.
You know, but it wasn't intentional.
Yeah, in retrospect, it all makes sense,
but of course, these are experiences
collected over a long period of time.
I mean, in the series of books and in your podcast,
you know, how many times is it like, we met in 1994?
Like, these are people that have been in your life,
these artists are people who you've known
for a very long time, like that you sought out,
that you were curious about, that you were interested in
and developed a relationship.
I don't know whether it was intentional
or just a result of that curiosity,
but it seems like you made a concerted effort to, you know,
figure out how to, you know,
be connected to people who you felt were on the rise
or doing something interesting and worthy of note.
Yeah.
So, a really good friend of mine is a guy
by the name of Michael Govan.
He's the director of the LA County Museum of Art,
and he loves art,
and I love art, you know?
I hope so. (chuckles)
But not everyone necessarily in our role does, you know,
so I think it's important to kind of point that out,
and some people love art,
but they don't love artists, you know?
So, I love artists.
You know, Michael does, too.
He shared this wisdom with me at some point,
and he said, you know, "It's really up to us to write
our own histories and to tell our own stories,"
and he said, "you know, like a museum director,
their history is amongst the artists that they choose
to associate themselves with."
And he said, "So, you know, who are your people?
You know, who are the people that you want
to be aligned with, you know, throughout history?"
And so, there are artists who I've known, as you said,
a really long time, who I've done, like Doug Aitken.
So, Doug Aitken was,
I met Doug, he got off the plane,
flew from LA to New York.
He was renting the studio
of an artist named Lawrence Carroll,
who, unfortunately, passed away in the last few years.
Keith Edmier, another artist, and I were there.
Keith was hanging Sheetrock 'cause he had rented
this studio for the summer,
and we were the first people that Doug met.
The first show that I had an idea for, I pitched to Doug,
and you know, classically now, he's like,
"Well, that's a good idea, what else do you have,"
and I was like, "Oh, my God, it took me like a year
to come up with one idea.
Like, what do you mean what else do I have?"
But he was in the first show I curated, which was in Paris.
I did a solo show with him at the Berkeley Art Museum,
bought a major work of his,
did a solo show at the Aspen Art Museum.
He's in my book, and in the most recent version
of this book, it's the only conversation where he's,
they're not interviews, they're conversations,
but he asks the questions of me.
You know, we've known each other 30 years.
Yeah, the book opens with that.
I mean, you have a brief introduction, or forward,
and then it's that interview,
where you're really the focus of it.
And yeah, he's like, remember when you guys talk
about, like, "Remember when we had to schlep
all the artwork to Paris," it's like back in the day,
and it's like these relationships are genuine
and authentic because you were there at the inception
of a lot of these people's careers that are now, you know,
at the kind of, you know, sharp edge of what's interesting
about the art world.
Yeah.
That's, I mean, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
So, you have this Christie's experience.
You work in a bunch of galleries.
At some point, you end up, (clears throat)
then you're at the Jewish Museum after that, right?
And that seems like that was kind of a tipping point
for you, though, to kind of be not just one
of the many people who come to New York
and end up working in these galleries,
but like, okay, this is like a serious,
potentially sustainable career path.
Yeah.
It's interesting because I,
I always, once I decided I wanted to work in the art world,
and you're right, like I was there exactly when you knew me,
I was kind of a gallery girl, right,
and there are tons of 'em.
Right.
If you're pretty and young,
like you get invited to every party,
and you know, it's super easy to, like, enter the art world.
People think it's hard.
It's super easy to get in,
and it's like right place, right time, right outfit,
you know, kinda thing, right?
But that's different from being taken seriously.
Exactly, and so, pretty quickly,
I said, like, "I want to earn my place here.
I don't want to just be someone's guest," right,
and I got involved
with an emerging gallery
that was called the AC Project Room.
And an artist named Byron Kim,
I've always been good at talking to artists,
and he had the idea for me to do these conversations.
So, I've been doing these conversations
with artists for a really long time.
I didn't kind of formalize them until not that long ago,
but that's part of what I've done.
I really love the conversation and the dialogue,
and at some point, I wanted to work in a museum,
because I thought at first,
I don't want to work in a museum and I don't want to teach,
but those were the things that I realized
could have a much broader impact.
You know, having
my own gallery or whatnot,
which I did a little bit with my first husband,
I was already just talking to people
who already cared about art.
I wanted to kind of proselytize, you know,
about art and the role that it could have in people's lives,
and moving to the Jewish Museum and doing shows there,
I felt like I had just sharpened my skillset, you know,
to convince people that didn't already, like, know
and like me that these things were important.
Yeah, but you had this practice pre podcast
of seeking out artists and having a conversation with them,
and then either recording it or taking notes,
and you've saved all of that, right?
Like, it's a very cool practice
that reminds me of Brian Grazer, you know, that producer?
Yes.
Who talks often and fondly
about a similar practice,
where, you know, going back,
all the way to the beginning of his career,
as a young person, he would just seek out these mentors
or cold-call people and take them to lunch
or convince them to go to lunch with him
so he could learn from them, and then he would write up
all these notes, and he has like, you know,
a library full of wisdom that he's accumulated
by just, you know, pursuing that practice,
and it feels like what you've done
is pretty similar to that.
Yeah.
Yes or no?
Yes, yes, you know?
Yeah.
I've been thinking about legacy in the last few years,
and it started sort of going to a college reunion
around when my son graduated from high school.
It was the 40th anniversary of the Aspen Art Museum,
and we had commissioned this essay around the museum,
and it was supposed to be, I don't know,
2,000 words or something like that,
and it ended up being like 15,000, you know.
And it wasn't about me, but I was like a key character
in the story, and I remember reading it on the plane
on the way to my college reunion,
and it just felt like this punctuation, you know?
I wasn't planning to leave the museum,
I didn't have any thoughts of it,
and somehow I had this really strange sensation
reading this story, where it's like someone else
giving me this perspective on, you know, what I had done,
and your sharing that with me just now
and your knowing me for such a long time is this,
it has a weight to it, like a veracity,
that maybe someone else saying it,
you know, I would kind of brush off.
It's an incredible gift, to have someone who knows you well,
or knows you for a long time, or who pays attention,
to reflect back
your life.
It's pretty amazing.
Yeah.
Thank you for that observation.
I think it's well earned on your part,
and in terms of legacy, like I was trying to figure out,
are you, like, I sensed a little bit of emotionality
around that and I wasn't sure whether it was, like,
healthy pride for cool things that you've done
that have meaning or whether it's that sense of, like,
it being an epitaph, like I'm just starting,
like this is the story of my life,
'cause if you think about legacy, all you have to do is look
at the Aspen Museum of Art.
I mean, that building will outlast all of our lifetimes,
and it's, you know, basically a symbol
of that entire city, right?
Yes.
And you made that happen,
which is, like, unbelievable, right?
Yep.
You must feel,
like, amazing about that, and I know it's controversial
in the community, but it feels like everyone
has kind of come around to embracing it.
But with that probably comes, like, okay, well, what's next,
or do I have to top that, or where am I going?
And I remember you reaching out to me after you left Aspen,
and you were like, you know, "I'm trying to figure out
what I'm gonna do next," and you had this HiZ.art thing,
and it had to do with these conversations
and how to figure out how to create
a digital platform for them.
And then, Orange County called.
Yep.
That's right.
So, HiZ.art got, like,
sidelined for a bit,
or it just got turned into podcasts in the books?
I think both, you know?
I had an idea when I left the museum,
and, you know, I set out on this kind of journey,
like of self-discovery, right?
I literally, you know, went halfway around the world.
I booked a ticket from, you know, Denver to Bangkok,
and I figured I'll just figure it out once I land,
and it was the first time, I mean, I'm super lucky,
I've traveled a ton, and it was the first time
that I ever went somewhere by myself, and with no itinerary.
And I ended up doing a yoga retreat in Laos,
which was something I had wanted to do,
the idea of a yoga retreat, my whole life.
I basically have had kids my entire career,
so, you know, focused on kids and career,
not really on self.
And then, I ended up going to Angkor Wat,
and then to, you know,
to a Buddhist meditation training
in Thailand, and when I was there, you know,
I had this realization, which, you know, maybe sounds trite,
but I was like, everything I'm looking for, I already have.
You know, it's like right here.
Right.
So, coming back, you know,
I was like, okay, I'm gonna do these conversations,
I'm gonna travel around, I'm gonna create this platform,
and then COVID happened,
and, you know, it's like the music stops
and you just are in whatever chair,
you know, was empty, right?
And we were in Scottsdale,
and, like, no offense to anyone,
but Arizona is not my place,
and through the course of being there,
it was really, really lonely, you know?
And so, absent of a team,
'cause I had worked with a team for a really long time,
and absent of, like, pretty much any friends,
you know, and I just thought, like, hmm,
I thought I wanted to do this thing on my own,
but I didn't like it.
So, yes, the Orange County Museum of Art called,
and I said, "I'm not sure, you know, what I want to do,"
but I was coming to Orange County for a horse show
with my daughter, who's an equestrian,
and I said I'd like to go on a hardhat tour
and check it out, and I did,
and I could see what it could be.
Yeah.
So, and that was,
when was that, like a year and a half ago?
That was in July of 2020.
Right, and the difference between Aspen and Orange County,
when you were at Aspen, you raised all this money.
You commissioned the architect, Shigeru Ban,
to build the building you saw.
You saw, you know, that whole process,
from origination through completion, but in Orange County,
the construction of the new museum was already underway.
Yeah.
So, Thom Mayne
had already designed it and construction was happening.
I'm sure it was slowed down by the pandemic,
but you're kind of stepping into a situation
that you're familiar with 'cause you'd experienced
that before, but probably not coming in
with the same level of agency.
Yeah.
Really interesting process,
and a couple of different points, again,
that you can't make this stuff up.
In 2008, when the Aspen Art Museum
was looking for an architect, there were three finalists.
One was Shigeru Ban, one was Thom Mayne,
and one was a Swiss firm, Gigon and Guyer.
And in 2008, the Orange County Museum of Art
was also looking for an architect,
and their three finalists were Thom Mayne,
Shigeru Ban, and an Argentinian firm.
So, I knew about this project for a long time,
and I had known Thom a little bit, you know, since then,
and so I had my eye on the project,
and, yeah, I mean, part of the reason I took the job
is because I wanted to kind of prove to myself
that I wasn't like a one hit wonder, you know,
that it wasn't just like a certain place
that I could do this thing.
I think one of the reasons I was interesting
to the Orange County Museum of Art
is 'cause I had done it before,
and when the project opens,
I'll be the only woman in America
to have done two ground-up museum projects.
That's pretty cool.
So, the project had started,
the construction had started,
and although there were 17 designs over 14 years,
there were still opportunities for me to enhance the design
and to add my experience as an operator to the design
because Thom has designed other museums,
but not other art museums.
And so, I was able to come in and say,
"Hey, you know, we need to change the lighting."
You know, "People will use the building in this way.
We need to make these enhancements."
You know, they had pulled out the photovoltaics
for, you know, value engineering, and I said, you know,
"I'm an environmentalist,
we have to have the photovoltaics."
So, I do feel like, even though I inherited the architect
and I inherited the design,
I did get to personalize it a little bit.
I could add to it, there was something for me to do.
And it's on schedule for October,
to open?
October 8th, 5:00 p.m.,
24-hour opening.
Super exciting.
I think there's like a $97 million budget,
or something like that, that I read.
This is no small project.
Yeah, hopefully it's 94,
but it's- (laughing)
(laughing) And I know,
I re-listened to the podcast that you did with Lance
on Lance's show, and you were talking
about keeping it on schedule, like it just had to open up
that date, and everybody was gonna say,
well, you know, it's inclement weather,
like, we're gonna need a couple more months,
and you were able to, like, stick the landing
and open it as promised.
That is true.
That is true, yeah.
Yeah.
And that was the first podcast I was ever on,
and Lance is a, you know, great longtime friend,
and he was a supporter of the Aspen Art Museum.
And the story that you're referencing, you know, I sat down,
the head of the building committee, you know,
invited me to lunch, maybe in New York,
and he, you know, said he was kind of trying to give me
like a, you know, like, I don't know if you can say it,
like come to Jesus, right, and he was like,
"You know, this isn't gonna happen," and I was like,
"Yes, this has to happen."
Right.
You know, we kind of went back and forth, and he was like,
"I don't think you understand," and I was like,
"No, I don't think you understand."
And he was great, you know, great to work with him,
and yeah, a lot of things can get done through sheer will.
So, this one will open on time as well.
Yes, it will.
Yeah.
Another interesting kind of weird thread
is that Thom Mayne was the mentor to Lorcan O'Herlihy,
who's the architect that we worked with
on our house.
Yes.
So, those threads.
Yeah.
That layered even more.
And Thom's amazing.
He's got a great story.
He's a visionary.
Yeah.
You know, he's a son of, you know, Orange County, LA,
you know, born in Indiana
and moved out to California, raised by a single mom,
and, you know, also, through sheer will,
has built this incredible career, and I mean, genius.
He's a genius.
Yeah, I mean,
he's responsible for kind of creating
the architectural iconography of Los Angeles in many ways,
like it all tracks back to him,
so that has to be a cool, enriching experience.
Well, let's talk about art in general.
I think art, it's like, how do we talk about art, right?
Well, this is what you do for a living.
Art means many things to many people.
So, how do you think about what art is,
like how do you define it for yourself?
So, the way I define it
for other people is also kind of how I define it for myself,
but people often ask me that,
and I have a super simple definition.
What I say is that if the person who made it says it's art,
then it's art.
So, it's all about the intention.
It's about the intention of the creator.
And so, if you go through the galleries
of The Metropolitan Museum of Art
and you see like a beautiful Islamic bowl,
you know, from the 9th century,
I love that.
You know, that's part of my aesthetic.
You know, is that art, or is that artifact?
Well, you know, probably it's artifact
because it was used to prepare food, to present food, right?
If it was created to be put up on a shelf to, you know,
represent something that is not utilitarian,
then it's an art object.
So, if I take this and I move it over here,
and I say, "Do you like my art, Rich,"
and you're like, "Uh,"
(Rich laughing)
you get to have an opinion, and you can say, like,
"Yes, I think that's so amazing,
the way the light hits the water," you know,
or you can say, like, "No, because, you know,
it's only three quarters full,
and I would like it if it was, like, 100% full."
Like, you get to have an opinion about it.
You get to judge it,
whether it's, like, good or bad,
or you like it, or you don't,
but no one gets to say that it's not art,
you know, if I made it and I said it's art.
Intentionality is all of it, then.
So, anybody can say anything is art,
and we're not, we're not able
to say, "No, it's not."
Correct.
That's a pretty bold definition.
Yes.
That might make
some people angry.
That's okay, you know.
I did a donor trip to New York some years ago,
and we went to the studio of an artist named Gedy Sibony,
and he does lots of things, but at the time,
he was taking carpet remnants and turning them around
and hanging them on the wall, kind of like paintings, right?
And a guy who was on the trip was so mad.
He was like so offended by this
'cause I was like, "This is so interesting,
look at the tape mark on it and how it's been cut
and, you know, how it comes off the wall,"
and he was like, "Is this "The Emperor's New Clothes" thing?
Are you trying to embarrass me?
Are you trying to make me feel stupid?"
Like, he was really angry,
and he even insisted that we go out to dinner
once we had gotten back to Aspen
'cause he wanted to talk about it.
It still bothered him like two weeks later,
and I won't use his name, but I said, "You know what?
Maybe the fact that you're still thinking about this
and still angry about it means that it's actually good."
Yeah, who wins in that situation?
If it's haunting him,
then that obviously is an argument
that it does have some level of artistic merit.
Yeah, or at least just worthy
of being considered.
As a piece of, you know,
being a provocateur, a provocative piece of something.
Yeah, you know, I would much rather have someone,
it's not like I want to make anyone mad,
that's not what I'm saying,
and I want people to care about stuff, you know?
I think, like, lack of curiosity and apathy
are what's gonna kill, not just individuals,
but, like, society.
So, I think it's great,
you know, for people-
Well, let's move
into that then, like why does art matter?
(Heidi laughing)
Right?
I'm sure you get asked these questions all the time.
No, I'm just laughing because, you know, on my podcast,
the one thing that I ask everyone is,
"Why does art matter?"
Yeah, I know.
And I figured you knew,
and I've had this kind of personal campaign
since I took the job in Aspen in 2005,
where I wanted to kind of make the statement
that by asking the question, "Why does art matter,"
it's not, "Does art matter,"
it's, "Why does it matter?"
So, inherent in the question is, like,
the assertion that it does.
You're assuming
that it already does, yeah.
Exactly.
So, that was intentional on my part,
and, you know, I think that art matters
because it is, it's like an alternate language.
It's a way of communicating things
that have no other way to be told.
And earlier today, I had a meeting with a journalist,
and she was saying that she had studied poetry,
and she went to her kid's class
and they were doing a poetry project,
and they had a similar thing,
like, you know, why does poetry matter, and she said,
or maybe they said, like, "What is poetry,"
and she said, "Poetry is extraordinary language,"
and I was like, "That's amazing."
Like, I love this idea of the extraordinary,
and you know, she was saying, like,
metaphor and simile matter,
not 'cause we're trying to compare everything,
but it's a way of giving us an ability to talk about things
that we don't have an ability to talk about otherwise.
So, art, for me, communicates things
that everything else fails short
to do.
There's a difference between art
in that kind of expanded concept
versus the experience of art in the museum setting.
Like when we think about art,
we think about paintings hanging on a wall,
or we think about a statue that's in the middle
of a room in a museum, and when we think about museums,
and I'm as guilty of this as anybody,
and I'm certainly no savvy art person,
but that experience
conjures for me,
like, names on a wall of donors
who tend to be kind of robber baron, Vanderbilt-type people
that you'll never meet,
cryptic descriptions of the artists and the art
that would confound even the most earnest person
who's trying to understand what this is,
and kind of an environment that can be cold
and intimidating and somewhat off-putting.
It's like the museum is about money,
endowments,
donors, prestige,
power, and fancy parties.
Yeah, that's-
So, disabuse me of this idea
or help me understand how we can,
'cause I know, like, at the center of everything that you do
is this deep desire to democratize the art experience,
to make it accessible and meaningful for everybody,
because under your definition of what art is,
it should be speaking to all of us.
It has the power to elevate all of our life experience,
but we need a better way to communicate about it
and a better way to, like, access it.
I agree with that last statement a lot,
and I have spent
a lot of time thinking about why, you know,
why do a lot of people not care about art,
because a lot of people don't care about art,
and that was really, that was kind of my sabbatical project,
you know, and that was part of the HiZ.art platform,
is, you know, like what can I do personally
to take art directly to the people,
how can I mainline art,
and I thought that I wanted to move away from a building
that can be intimidating or associative
with exactly what you're talking about.
So, you know, is there a more direct vehicle to communicate
with the broadest possible audience about art?
I have been listening to the recent Brené Brown book,
and one thing that was in there that really stood out for me
was about this idea, and you know, you may have read it
or, you know, heard it as well,
which is that, it was about curiosity and brain function
and how we literally cannot be curious about something
that we know nothing about.
You have to have some seed from which to be curious,
and so if people have no knowledge of art
or no access point for art,
then, of course, they're not gonna be curious about it,
and people don't care about things
that they're not curious about.
So, how do you get over that hurdle,
those associations of contemporary art
with, you know, an Andy Warhol silkscreen
that just sold for $195 million to Larry Gagosian, right,
like all these things that work against this notion of art
being this system of energy, this means of communication?
So, you know, we make some progress,
and then something like that happens, right,
so there's this kind of push/pull, you know, within that.
So, for me, part of what I'm trying to do
with the Orange County Museum of Art is to build
what I'm referring to as a museum of the 21st century,
and part of the way that we're doing that
is through an exhibition program that has three tenets.
One of the tenets is looking back to look forward,
and so this idea
of not thinking like you're the first person
that's ever had this idea, right,
or not thinking like, you know, it's only about us,
well, you know, right now, and what can we consume,
and what do we need, and how are we satiated, you know?
And, you know, the next tenet is about place
and being really cognizant that, you know,
particularly during the COVID period, and after,
like, you know, as I said, like the music stopped,
and you were, you know, you were where you were,
and so, like, you know, what did you learn
about, like, yourself absent of motion?
You know, so many people spend, myself included,
so much time in motion, you know, that there was,
you know, a time that we wouldn't maybe otherwise have had
to say, like, "Well, who am I,"
not just, "Where am I?"
And then the third tenet we're calling caring and sharing,
you know, and it's about this idea we want the museum to be,
like, you know, a Netflix series or great restaurant
or, you know, something that you say to your friend,
like, "Hey, you have to check this out,"
like, "Let's go and do that together, I'll take you there,"
and so to not have the museum be like I'm telling you
what's great and what you should care about
because I'm some authority figure.
Right, or it feels like homework.
Yes, exactly.
As opposed to something
you're excited to check out.
Exactly.
It's one thing to say that or to set out to achieve that,
but what is the mechanism to hook people in?
I mean, I know one big thing is you have
a donor that's allowing you to make the museum free
for the first 10 years, so you've removed that hurdle,
which I think is huge.
Yeah.
But how do you get people talking about it and excited?
So, in Aspen, we did a project called Arte en Español,
and, you know, we really wanted to reach out
to the Spanish-speaking community,
and, you know, a lot of times,
institutions would say, like, "Hey, you know,
we have an artist from Mexico,"
like, "you guys should come,"
and it's like, "Well, you know, why," right?
So, we developed this partnership
with a Spanish language radio station called La Tricolor,
and at the time, the director of learning
and myself, you know, spoke Spanish,
and, you know, went on the station
and invited people to come.
And so, the first time, we thought, you know,
maybe we'd get 15 people, and we got 50, you know,
and the second time, we thought maybe we'd get 15,
and we got like 300.
And so, the learning from that
was something that we'll put in play here, too,
which is people want to be invited, you know?
Like, no one wants assumptions
to be made about them or their values
or, you know, what they should care about, right?
People want to be seen, people want to be heard,
people want to feel like you want them specifically.
You know, it's like you get an invitation
that's, like, to a whole bunch of people,
and you're like, yeah, I mean, maybe I'll go,
but if you get like a handwritten note,
or someone comes by your house, you know, or your office,
and they're like, "Hey, I'm doing this thing,
and I'd really like you to be there,"
it makes a huge difference.
So, I think that's part of what we're doing,
is, you know, working really hard
to be aware of the, like, unassumed biases
or assumed biases, or, you know,
to really be open and courageous about having conversations
that are uncomfortable, and to say, like,
"Okay, maybe it was this way before.
I'm sorry."
You know, like, "What else can I do?"
Yeah.
One of the things that I thought was really cool
about what you did in Aspen
was the outreach to the community.
I mean, Aspen's a very interesting place.
We think of it as being this,
you know, ski resort town that's very hoity-toity
and movie stars, et cetera,
but that's not the legacy or the history of that place.
That's a sort of recent development.
I mean, there was this counterculture hippie situation,
and then the vast history that preceded that.
Rickey was filling me in on a bunch of this the other day,
but the fact that the museum, through your leadership,
was connected to, like, a nearby rehab facility,
and the work that you did with, like,
the veterans community,
to bring them into that art experience
as a healing modality.
Yeah.
That's super important to me, you know, and I think
that sort of the highest order
of living is to be of service,
and so, you know, we hear about, like, servant leaders,
and I really put that at the forefront
of what I do every day,
is, you know, like how can I help?
And so, I'm an ideas generator, I'm like a visionary, right,
but I also am great-
Since Doug Aitken said,
"What else," you're like,
"I need to be better about my idea generation."
Quicker, yeah.
Yeah.
I got way quicker at it,
but you know, it's one thing to have an idea,
it's another thing to execute.
So, I've spent a lot of time thinking about, you know,
how can we help, like what can we do, you know,
and a story that I love to tell
is a collaboration that we did in Aspen,
and I'm talking kind of about that now
because the Orange County Museum of Art isn't open yet.
So, like you said, I can say things, but we have to do 'em,
but these are things, you know, that were done.
I reached out to the Hope Center,
which is a suicide prevention center in Aspen,
and I've lost some really important people
in my life to suicide, and that's one of the causes
that I, you know, work on behalf of,
and I said, "You know, I'd like to help.
Can you come to the museum and have a meeting,
and let's, you know, brainstorm."
So, you know, I met with the founder and the director,
and at first, they said, "Well, you know,
can you raise money for us," and I was like,
"No, I can't raise money for you,"
like maybe personally, but not as an institution.
And then they said, "All right, well, can you show art
that's made by, you know, our clients,"
and I was like, "No, you know, we can't do that either,
but tell me what you do."
So, you know, people call there
if they are in immediate danger
of personal harm than 911, hospital, et cetera,
and if people can be, like,
moved to a different place psychologically,
then they're given a list of safe spaces to go,
and I said, "Great, can we make the museum a safe space?"
So, we did frontline training for all of our employees
so that the museum could be a safe space,
and the idea is that, you know, sometimes all it takes
is like one person being kind to you
to move you from, like, this moment to this moment,
and it's in between those moments that you're at risk.
So, I can't remember what the question was,
but-
Yeah, well,
it was really about how you leverage your position
and your love of art and your belief in its ability
to be this vehicle for healing
or community or, you know,
anything, really, that is aspirational, right,
and how you channel that into service.
Like, okay, I'm in this privileged position,
I have this job, this role,
but I have the opportunity to be creative within that,
and how can I give back to the community
and instill in them some version of this passion
that I have that is so meaningful to me personally?
Yeah, and, you know, museums,
you know, so I'm back in the museum space,
I'm back in a building,
and there are certain constraints around that, you know,
but in other ways, it's also incredibly expansive.
You know, it's associative,
people know that's a place for art.
Museums are places that are often quiet, you know?
Yeah.
And so, it's great
for people with autism, you know,
like it's reduced stimulation of, you know, sound and light
'cause everything's super controlled, right?
So, there are things that we're in a really great position
to be of help with.
When you think about education
and the way that kids are taught art,
like, what are your thoughts on that?
You know, we learn from things
that are positive and negative, right?
So, I remember being at the Rothko Chapel in Houston once,
and that's one of my, like, favorite places,
like it's a go-to place for me,
and there was a group of kids, they were coming from school.
They were, you know, dressed in their school uniforms,
and their teacher said,
"Okay, go in, keep moving, don't touch anything, don't stop.
Walk to the end, take a left.
Walk to the end, take a left, come back out,"
and I was like, "Oh, my God."
Like, this is this incredible place of contemplation
and quiet and solitude and, like, you know,
magnitude and humanity, and here they're being told,
like, "You don't belong," right?
Like, "Don't do all these things,
I'm gonna assume that you're gonna do everything negative,"
instead of like, "Hey, go inside," you know,
"tell me which one is your favorite when you come out."
Like, "What do you think of," you know?
Like, "Keep your voice quiet
so other people can have contemplation."
There are ways to say the same thing, you know, differently.
So, I don't know what kids are being taught about art now.
You know, my kids went to Aspen Country Day School at first,
and, you know, they're three years apart in terms of grades,
and they had the same assigned (laughing) art project.
Like, it didn't evolve.
It didn't evolve
at all.
No, and it didn't evolve
any kind of creativity-
Like draw within the lines,
and if you do anything creative, that's no bueno.
Like, it's really a creativity killer,
which is the opposite of the whole intention behind it.
For sure, and I remember one of my kids actually got
in trouble because they didn't follow the assignment,
and I was like, but art is not
about an assignment, what do you mean?
Like, I would think you would get an A
if you don't follow the assignment.
(upbeat synth music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know,
who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so, I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book, "Voicing Change, Volume Two".
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book,
worthy of display on any coffee table,
and Volume Two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change, Volume Two",
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today
only at richroll.com.
How do you think
about the role of art in this area of offense?
Like, we're very hypersensitized right now,
and we're going through, you know,
a lot of cultural shifts at the moment, for better or worse.
Like, you know, this is part
of what moves us forward as a culture,
but there does seem to be trepidation
around saying the wrong thing,
and how does that fit with art,
which is about being provocative or pushing the envelope
or making people uncomfortable?
Yeah, you know, I like to give everyone the benefit
of the doubt, you know,
and that's how I like to just approach my life, you know?
And, like, yeah, sometimes people
say things that are triggering
or offensive, you know, and I like to believe
that, you know, everyone does the best they can
with the information that they have at the time.
And, sure, like, I'm gonna say things wrong sometimes,
and other people are gonna say the wrong thing sometimes,
and, you know, to come at things with, again,
this kind of grace for people, you know,
and a belief in, like, the inherent, you know, goodness,
I think, is how, you know, I try and approach art, too.
And I think, you know, I've been in situations
where I'll say like, you know,
I'm not really sure if I can say this or, you know,
like, is this okay, and that kind of humility, you know,
to be open in that way, you know,
with that kind of grace and dignity
for whomever you're talking to or about,
I think that's the only answer I can give.
And what about the role of the artist themselves, though,
'cause they play a role in how we think
about what's happening around us,
how we contextualize and make sense of, you know,
confusing things about our world
and what it means to be human,
and in a confusing time,
I suppose you can make the argument that the artist
plays a role in trying to create clarity.
I hope so, you know,
but clarity for who, right?
Right.
So, I mean-
Well, usually,
through their personal experience.
Exactly, yeah.
Yeah.
And so, there's an amazing Barbara Kruger show
up right now in LA,
and, you know, she's interested
in the dynamics of power, right?
And that's something that I'm interested in
and that I've changed my perspective on, you know,
certainly as I've grown up, and, you know,
what is the responsibility of power, and who has it,
and, yeah, I think art can shed the light on that.
You know, I'm less interested in art that is didactic,
just like I'm less interested in people
who are, you know, prescriptive or didactic.
You know, I'm interested in openness and expansiveness,
and I'm more interested in questions
than I am in answers.
Yeah, Kruger's interesting
because she's been doing this for a very long time
and has been very consistent in her messaging,
and yet has there been a time where her message,
you know, could be more resonant than it is now?
Like, I just saw, when I went down to see Rickey,
the side of the MOCA is like painted in a giant, you know,
giant, what do you call that?
It's like a billboard.
Mural kind of, yeah, yeah.
Like, the whole side of the building is painted
with one of her pieces.
Yeah.
So, it's cool.
We have to keep learning the same things
over and over again.
(laughs) I know, right?
Yeah, not just personally, but also as a society,
you know, and it's like, that can be depressing
or it can just be a truth, you know?
I said to my son the other day, you know, I mean,
"I don't think life is like really circular anymore,
I'm thinking about it like as a corkscrew," you know?
So, it's like, yes, you keep coming back around,
one keeps coming back around,
and hopefully, you're in a slightly elevated place,
you know, to experience the same thing,
so you're not the same as you experience the same thing.
That's almost like a weird,
like, kind of "Inception" way of thinking.
Well, like a metaverse,
sort of a parallel universe's way of thinking about life
and sliding doors.
Yeah.
Well, I mean,
I catch myself
in some of the same situations,
and it's like the knowledge I've accumulated
allows me to make different decisions.
Meditation has played a big role in this.
Yes.
You're on, like, a tear.
How many days without missing a day?
It's like 1300 days, or some crazy number like that,
of consistently meditating.
So, what has been your experience
of being so consistent with that practice?
I'm a totally different person.
I am, like, certain that my brain has been, like, rewired
and, like, the space between stimulus and response, right,
it's much longer.
So, not every single time, you know?
There are moments when I still react,
and most of the time, I respond,
and that's because of meditation.
Yeah.
Anything else?
You know, I'm a super ritualistic person.
I do the same things, same five things, every day,
and I eat the same stuff,
and actually, apparently,
I need a little more variety. (laughs)
I don't know,
if it's working for you-
I know.
I'm going back and forth about it, you know?
Like, my naturopath said I need more variety,
but my homeopath said, like, it's good, you know,
so I don't know, who do you listen to?
I mean, I guess you listen to yourself, but I'm doing this,
I like, I like to do things that are hard, right?
You know, we talked about Rickey's project,
and so one of the things I'm doing in 2022
is 365 days of yoga,
and so it's, I'm less about, like, how long I meditate
or, you know, how long I do yoga for or whatever,
but it's about the consistency.
So, I do these same things every day,
and somehow there's a lot of comfort for me in knowing,
like, these are just my things.
It's interesting, in your "Conversations with Artists",
that ritual comes up,
like you ask people about their habits.
Yeah.
And I'm just remembering
your conversation
with Tom Sachs and him sharing his morning routine,
and that really, like, hit me hard.
Do you remember what he said?
You know, I don't.
I remember what he said about, like,
how he knows what kind of artist someone is
based on what they're wearing.
Oh, yeah,
that's a very Werner Herzog thing, or he's like,
he gives them a broom and says, "Sweep the floor,"
and he watches how they sweep the floor,
and then he knows whether they're gonna be a fit.
Yeah, yeah, but I don't remember what he said,
I think something about his coffee.
So, well, he was talking about how we need
to be very mindful of not squandering those morning hours
because sleep is this precious thing,
where your unconscious mind is coming up
with all of these ideas and, like,
processing all of this information,
and when you first wake up in the morning,
it's accessible and present,
and to do anything but respect that
and channel it into something creative
is to kind of waste that gift that you get every single day.
And so, he had a couple of sayings, one of which was like,
"Don't read the newspaper until your hand has touched clay,"
you know, which could be a metaphor
for many things, obviously,
but to treat those morning hours as something
very special and sacred.
Yeah.
I thank you for that, I do remember that now,
and I think a lot about that, too,
and that's a big part of why I have this morning ritual,
because I do believe that,
and it's not just me, I mean, this is,
a lot of people think this and have said this, you know,
but the way that you start your day, you know,
sets the tone for your whole day,
and if you populate your mind with, like,
other people's thoughts or problems or, you know, whatever,
it changes your emotion.
And so, you know, I love the morning,
and that's my most kind of creative time,
most productive time,
and it, yeah, it sets my tone for the day,
and any day that I even don't meditate until, like,
later in the day, it just doesn't go as well.
Yeah, you've got to do it first thing, right?
Among all of these many, many conversations that you've had
with artists for many years,
obviously there's gonna be recurring themes
or things that kind of connect all of these people
in some sort of unified theory.
So, what is that for you?
What do you glean
from speaking to all of these highly creative people
that would be meaningful for somebody
who's listening to this who maybe doesn't feel
that connected to art or the creative process?
I think one of the things that comes up a lot,
and people use different terms for it,
but it's the same thing,
and it's about kind of the flow state
and, you know, what do you do in your life
that allows you to forget everything else,
and, you know, when do you most feel like yourself,
and it's when you're not aware of what's happening.
And so, you know, I had a friend of mine,
who is the CEO of the Aspen Skiing Company, on the podcast,
and, you know, he finds it on the mountain.
You know, he finds it in skiing, right?
And so, everyone does something
when they feel that in the day.
For some people, it's washing the dishes, you know.
It's like the warm water on your hands, you know.
Some people, it's, you know, running
or, you know, walking the dog.
You know, for most people,
it is like somehow being in motion
and/or being removed from your devices, you know.
So, for me, it's also in the shower, you know.
I think that in that space, like, that's where art happens,
and it's like the art of life as well.
You know, that's when you solve a problem
that, you know, has been plaguing you,
even, you know, whatever it is.
You know, it might be something that's technical
or mechanical, or it might be something that's, you know,
conceptual or emotional,
but being able to tap into that space,
this is something that everyone talks about.
That's the mystical side of it,
but I think there's also a very practical side of it.
I had Van Neistat in here, who worked with Tom,
back to Tom Sachs, worked with Tom for a long time,
and that episode was great 'cause he, like, disabuses you
of any idea that, you know, the artist is walking around,
just having lightning bulb moments constantly
and just, you know, sort of expressing,
you know, without any kind of toil or turmoil,
and that, in truth,
it's the result of a very diligent commitment to a practice
that is organized and well thought out,
and often extremely difficult and time-consuming.
All those things are true,
and what I would add to that as well
is that it's often lonely, you know?
And I think that loneliness is something that people
don't talk about a lot, and I think that it is like
a super broad, societal problem, you know?
And there's a benefit to loneliness, or alone time,
and it's not necessarily the same.
You know, you can be alone and not lonely,
and I think loneliness is more prevalent than people allow
because it seems like, you know, like maudlin
or, you know, like self, you know,
negative in some way, you know,
but that idea of being alone and/or being lonely
is necessary
for creativity as well
and not something that comes up, too.
Right, well, that plays into a bit of a stereotype,
that to be a brilliant, successful artist,
you must be tortured
and alone and isolated and self-flagellating,
and all of these things, but you know lots of artists.
Can you draw a conclusion about the general disposition
of the artist, or do they just come in all shapes
and sizes and flavors?
Artists are people,
you know, and all those adjectives that you just used,
like, they can all be teased out, you know?
So, it's like,
you can be,
you know, heady and contemplative
without being tortured, right?
You can be,
you know, tortured, but still, like, into it, you know,
like maybe that's not negative, right?
I mean,
I think that, you know, artists are people
who make things for other people, you know, and this idea
of, like, the mythology
of any kind of, like, group is almost always wrong.
Yeah, that idea of artists make things for other people
is an interesting one and, I feel,
like very dynamic in our age.
We were talking about Daniel Arsham
before the podcast and how his work
is one of (clears throat) constant collaboration with, like,
corporate partners, some of which are super cool,
like, oh, Adidas, and stuff like that,
and some that are like,
really, you're gonna work with that brand?
But in so doing, he's able to create
these sort of iconic works
that live outside of the museum space
and kind of penetrate culture
in a really interesting way.
It feels like that, that kind of sensibility,
maybe began with somebody like Warhol,
and he's carrying on that tradition,
but now, in this hyper-corporatized social media world,
us being Gen Xers and having hangups about selling out
is, like, not a thing anymore.
You know, it's like, oh, cool,
you're working with that brand,
or you're taking money from these people to make that thing.
We have a very different relationship, too,
than when we were in our 20s.
Yeah.
You know, I think I spend a lot of time
thinking about two things.
One, I really try and ask myself,
like, what would I love, you know,
and it goes back to the story that I told at the beginning
about Gary, you know, my stepfather.
You know, not what would I like,
you know, not like who do I love,
you know, but like what would I love,
you know, that allowance of the thing that would be,
you know, the greatest, highest,
best use, et cetera, you know?
And then, the other thing I think a lot about is,
you know, why does it matter,
you know, or what matters most, or who cares?
You know, it's kind of like the same question,
and being able to answer that, and one of the things
that matters a lot to me is amplification.
You know, it's like, if you're gonna do something,
like, you gotta make it worth doing,
and part of that is about its impact.
And so, you know, brand collaborations or things that, yeah,
previously, maybe I would've said, like,
"Well, I wouldn't do that," or like, you know, "No way,"
I'm like, "Okay, that's a vehicle," you know?
So, like Malcolm McLaren, you know, what's the message,
what's the medium, right?
Right, right, right.
And being okay about that.
Right.
And actually being grateful for it.
Yeah, I mean, when you,
I'm just remembering, like, around the time
when we were living in New York, everywhere you would go,
you would see Ravs painted on the side of buildings,
or you would see André the Giant, and you'd be like,
"Why is André the Giant everywhere,"
but there's something cool and provocative about that.
There's a mystery, like what is behind this,
like why are there pictures of this person
all over the city, and who's doing this,
that I think is really interesting in that sensibility,
like the urban landscape is the museum.
And I think that's why street art
is so kind of compelling and interesting,
because it is solving that accessibility problem,
and it is obviously democratizing the experience of art,
and it feels like it's this merging
of kind of culture
with art in the most seamless way possible, right?
Yeah.
So, how do you take
the best of what that is,
with you being somebody who's in charge of, like,
a building, you know, and encapsulate that in a way
that is meaningful for somebody who's coming in?
Yeah, and what I would also share in response to that
is like, Claude Monet's "Water Lilies", right?
I mean, I had a time, like in my 20s,
where I'm like, oh, God, you know, if it's on a dish towel,
like, I'm never looking at that art again, right,
and then going,
and on Naoshima Island, seeing these, you know,
incredible Claude Monet "Water Lilies" with natural light
and remembering like, oh, the reason that this
like jumped the shark, you know, and became part
of popular culture is 'cause it's amazing,
you know, because it's beautiful,
and I like things that are beautiful.
I wanted to read from your book.
You had mentioned earlier about the idea
of what would you love,
and you say in the latest book, in this volume,
"So, what if we ask ourselves in every moment of every hour
of every day for the rest of our lives, "What would I love?"
What if we allow ourselves the incredible gift
of connecting with our truest and deepest desires?
What if we believe we are not just able
or entitled to do so, but that we also know
that by granting ourselves this gift of connection,
we make the world better, better for ourselves,
our partners, our children, the planet?
What if the space of art encourages
and reinforces this notion?
What if the artist, by living fully
and outwardly and inspiringly and generously,
shares this notion as a woman, a mother, a partner,
a yogi, a generator, a friend, a community member?
What if paintings and sculptures and installations
can become incantations, prayers, experiences?
What if all the things are not just what they are,
but also more?
What if the entire universe
can be not only captured, but also encompassed,
both in the work of art and in the experience of it?
This is not just what I believe, but also what I know.
This is how I am inspired.
This is how I practice.
This is how I learn.
This is how I love.
This is how I am.
Amen."
So, it is a prayer in and of itself.
It's beautiful.
I haven't had that read to me.
Thank you.
Yeah.
How did you come to that approach
to how you think about art?
You know, in listening to you read that, I'm like,
how audacious of me to say that. (laughs)
Yeah, but you're entitled to own that, you know?
Yeah, how did I get there?
You know,
there are so many answers that I could give,
and it's sort of like the question of, you know,
how did I find my way to art?
I trace kind of,
I don't know if it's Heidi 2.0 or 3.0 or 6.0,
or whatever it is, but whoever I am, like, right now,
I trace a lot of it back
to the opportunity to meet this guy, Rand Stagen,
who has something called the Stagen Institute in Dallas,
and his introduction of me
to Joseph Campbell's "The Hero's Journey"
and giving me a framework for understanding
my life up until that moment,
and then marking that time
with a public talk, you know, for 300 people, all YPOers,
and then having him, you know, hug me at the end of it
and say, "You know, you just made a declaration
in front of your community,
and I'm so excited to see what happens."
And I was like, "What's a declaration,"
(laughing) you know, like what do you mean,
and it's a big part of that, you know, this idea
that there is some kind of system or structure
by which to quantify
and allow things that,
at the time, seemed like terrible, you know,
or difficult or awful or embarrassing or shameful,
and to see them within this space
of gratitude, you know,
for every single thing that's happened.
Right, 'cause they all hold meaning
that led you to this place.
Yeah.
Right?
Yeah,
and you know, for me, art is my North Star,
you know?
I love nature,
and that is a place
of, like, centering and grounding for me, you know,
and, like, the consistent thing through my life
for inspiration and, you know, joy
and company
is art.
You obviously have a really good radar
for people who are doing something interesting
and seeking out these artists.
So, you know, what is that?
Like, what are you looking for, or what is it
that triggers in you, like, oh, that person's interesting,
I want to know more about who they are?
It's often something that I don't understand.
We had an interesting conversation.
So, we spent Thanksgiving in Copenhagen with Laura
and her husband and kids, and we had a conversation
around the table around, you know, how we grew up.
And our father was an inventor, you know, 47 patents,
and he would talk at dinner
about these really complicated things
that no one understood,
and instead of feeling uncomfortable,
so we were both talking about, like, how did that inform us?
And, you know, Laura, it informed her to, like,
be, you know, an inventor, a creator,
like a kind of intergenerational gift in that way.
For me, it manifested as being, like, comfortable being,
like, not understanding things.
So, I don't feel threatened
by things that I don't understand.
I'm, like, curious about it,
or I'm like, "Okay, you get that,
and I love that you're passionate about that.
Like, that's not my thing,
but, like, that's cool," right?
So, what I'm often drawn to in an artist,
like, that thing is something I don't understand,
and it's not to say I understand a ton of things, you know,
but I understand a lot of things.
And so, when something happens that I don't quite get,
you know, that's what draws me in,
like whether it's the intention, well, like, why,
like why did you do that, or why does that matter to you,
or like, why are you thinking that?
Somewhere in those two spaces,
that's what I'm looking for.
Interesting.
What do you think about, like,
so who's interesting to you right now?
Like, I'm not gonna ask you who your favorite artist is,
but I will ask you, like, who's top of mind at the moment?
Who do you think, and you're like, wow,
that person's doing something next-level,
or, like, that is really cool?
So, there are so many artists, right,
and we can only show a super small number, right?
So, for us to give that kind of time
and space and, you know, to spend those funds, you know,
it has to be someone
who, you know, hits those three tenets, you know?
And sometimes it's someone that, you know,
I've known for a long time,
but haven't had the chance to work with yet,
and sometimes it's because I want to know more about someone
and, you know, spending more time with them.
There's an artist named Jennifer Guidi, who I really like,
and she's in one of the books,
and I like her ritual, you know.
I like her approach to making art.
I like that she's creating
these kind of contemporary mandalas,
these objects
for generating energy and sharing, like, that energy,
and it's, you know, it's a painting,
and it's made with sand, you know,
so it's not necessarily like a medium
that I've never thought of before.
I've just returned from Marfa, Texas,
and spent some time with Leo Villareal.
He's an artist I've known a really long time,
and he just made these NFTs, and I've been like,
oh, NFTs, you know, like we're talking about 'em
on the podcast and whatever 'cause, like, you have to,
'cause a big part of what I do is cultural consciousness,
because artists are, like, they're sponges
and they're reflectors, right, and that's what I am, too,
like simultaneously pull things in,
reflect things back, right?
And he has this great project
called "Cosmic Reef", and he explained it.
I took a bunch of Orange County Museum of Art donors,
and, you know, he explained it in a way
that made so much sense to everyone,
and you know what?
They're beautiful.
They're really beautiful.
They're NFTs?
Yeah.
There were two things that I wrote down on, like,
my outline that I wanted to talk to you about.
One is Marfa.
I want to understand, I've never been to Marfa,
but, like, I know Marfa's a big deal,
and I want to understand why.
And then, the NFT thing.
So, we'll put that aside for the moment.
Like, walk me through the whole Marfa thing.
Yeah.
So, the Marfa thing
is fascinating
for a lot of reasons
that I'll put in kind of a context.
This is my second visit,
and I saw some things for the second time on this trip,
and some of them I remembered
in a way that was true,
and some of the things I remembered differently
than they were true.
There are a lot of spaces that can be productive for art,
and sometimes art and artists go into places
that other people don't want to be 'cause it's cheaper,
it's far away, for whatever reason, right?
So, Marfa is literally in the middle of nowhere.
It's like not just far West Texas,
it's like far, far West Texas.
The first time I went there, to be super transparent,
we flew privately from Aspen, and I was like,
oh, it's not far, you know?
(Rich laughing)
It's, like, so convenient.
Yeah, okay.
Right?
Right.
Okay, this time-
But for people
that don't know, it's like,
it's this place in the middle of nowhere,
and there's a couple of buildings, there's not much, right,
and everybody knows the Prada store
that ends up on Instagram.
Prada Marfa.
Yeah.
So, there are two ways to get to Marfa, driving, okay?
You can fly in privately, but it's an airstrip,
and it's like the length of this table, okay?
So, you can fly to El Paso,
and it's a solid four-hour drive going 90
or a hundred miles an hour, okay?
So, it's not close to El Paso,
but that's the closest hospital, okay?
It's also a, you know, two hour and 45 minute drive
from Midland, Texas, okay?
That's where I went, and the drive from Midland, Texas,
is through, I mean, oil fields and trailers and, you know,
I mean, like it's a part of America that, you know,
I haven't seen much of.
And, you know, you're driving along the border
if you're coming from El Paso,
and there are like the big blimps that are looking,
you know, for people that are trying to cross the border.
I mean, it's, like, harsh.
It's at 5,000 square, sorry,
it's at 5,000 feet in elevation,
so, you know, there's the altitude issue.
And Donald Judd, who's really the father of minimal art,
was looking for a place to live and work,
and he had tried a lot of other places,
including Santa Fe and some places in Colorado,
and he had seen Marfa
while he was in the military,
while he was on a train that went through town,
and these long boxcar trains still go through town,
you know, every couple of hours.
You know, 200 cars,
you know, the train, engine,
West Texas light at altitude, so it looks different.
The light at altitude is different.
So, he bought up a bunch of military,
former military barracks,
places that German prisoners had been held,
and then he invited some of his friends
to do site-specific art there.
So, Donald Judd, Dan Flavin,
who's the artist that makes the work with fluorescent bulbs,
John Chamberlain, who's the artist
who makes the compressed car sculptures.
None of them are with us on the planet anymore.
And because it's a mecca,
you know, younger artists have moved there,
or not even necessarily, I mean,
there are younger artists, older artists.
We went to Christopher Wool's studio.
The head of the Chinati Foundation,
which is where the Donald Judds are
and the Chamberlains and the Flavins and Robert Irwin,
she said, "You can find a Donald Judd
behind every doorway here,
but good luck finding a sandwich on a Monday."
1400 people live there,
it's the poorest county in Texas,
and it's just a place with a lot of dichotomies,
and that's part of what makes it interesting.
The light is beautiful, it's quiet,
it's far from other places,
and it's, you know, worth going to.
The Prada Marfa that you're talking about
was commissioned by the Art Production Fund
and by the Ballroom Marfa,
and it's two artists, Elmgreen and Dragset,
and it was their idea,
and they actually were going to do Prada Vegas,
and then Yvonne Force,
who's one of the founders of the Art Production Fund,
said, "No, no, I have a better idea, you know, Prada Marfa."
And it's been shot at, it's been, you know,
the door was pulled off.
People stole the shoes and the bags.
And I don't know, some people love it now.
They put up a fence around the back of it,
and people have put locks on it, like, you know,
one of the Paris bridges,
but it's an unusual place.
So, yeah, it was a cattle town,
and now it's, I don't know if I would call it an art mecca,
but it's definitely a place
that draws the art world.
And it's a functioning
art commune, where working artists
are actually living there.
Yeah,
that's a little aggrandized, you know, to what it is.
It's a place where artists have found,
you know, some like-minded people
and have now driven up the cost of houses,
'cause people went on Zillow to check when we were there,
but I think it's pretty lonely and pretty isolated,
and there's a little bit of a battle for the town,
the soul of the town, I think, that's going on.
Yeah, it's fascinating.
There's something about it that is very resonant, though.
There's lots of, you know, kind of artist communities
around the world, but there's something about Marfa
that really draws a lot of people in
in a kind of special, intangible way.
Yeah, I think anything that's hard to do
makes something more interesting, you know?
So, I mean, I think-
Right, it weeds out
the looky-loos, right, 'cause it's so difficult
to get there.
Yeah, and I, you know,
I talked to the people that I brought with me,
and I said, "You guys are art pilgrims.
You know, you don't need me to take you to Miami,
you know, I'll take you to Inhotim, you know, in Brazil,
or I'll take you to Marfa, Texas."
Let's talk about the NFT thing.
So, we're in this,
in addition to being kind of in the era of offense,
we're also in the era of, like, content
and the era of, like, ephemera.
There's so much coming at us.
You said art is about intent,
but if everybody's putting all this stuff out into the world
on some, you know, somewhere on the spectrum of,
this is art, or this is just me sharing,
like, A, how do you make sense of all of that?
I mean, who is to say, like, TikTok is an art?
I don't know, like maybe you have a grip on that,
but that begs the whole NFT thing now.
So, it's a very strange time,
where I feel like art is at this pivotal moment
and at the center of the conversation
about what the evolution of the internet is gonna look like
and how we make sense of it.
And so, it sounds like, from the way you described it,
like, you're kind of like, "I don't know about all this,"
but you're slowly being lured in or converted to this idea
that real art can exist on that plane.
I mean, there's a difference between, I suppose,
like what Beeple's doing,
like grabbing headlines for commanding
these massive auctions,
or the Bored Ape Yacht Club versus, you know,
a bazillion JPEGs on OpenSea.
So, like, how do we make sense of all of that?
Yeah.
When people are trying to understand something,
they often conflate things, right?
And so, you'll hear people talk about, like,
why NFTs matter 'cause they'll say, like,
"Well, you know, an artist makes something,
and then it goes out in the world, and then it resells,
and they don't get anything for it,
and this solves that problem."
And I'm like, well-
That has nothing to do
with the art, though.
At all.
Yeah.
And that's like
the blockchain, right?
Right.
And that's about, you know?
Which is cool.
Which is super cool.
And very empowering
for artists out there.
Like, yeah.
Totally.
I'm all for that, you know,
but then it gets back to the McLaren thing, right,
like the medium or the message.
So, you have to separate the technology out
from the content, so the technology is cool,
you know, for that purpose, right?
Now, when something's new,
and then there's, you know, a huge amount of money
being associated with it,
then you have, it was like internet stocks
in, you know, like,
you know, early 2000s, right?
Early 2000s, yeah.
Or, you know, you have people
that just seize the opportunity,
and, you know, someone's like, "Well, I'll make my own NFT,
and I'll put it out there."
So, you know, a lot of the NFTs, particularly early on,
it really wasn't about the NFT,
it was really about crypto and a way of, like,
validating crypto and turning something that, you know,
seemingly had value, but, like, didn't have
any practical application into something, right?
So, that was like the primary driver, in my opinion.
The art has been secondary.
I think it's only recently
that people are trying to make things that are art
instead of what they said, you know.
I don't know, I want to be clear about it.
When I explained to you about my definition of art,
very quickly I said you get to have an opinion
about whether it's good or it's not, right?
And, like-
You can't say it's not art,
but it doesn't have to be good art.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah.
And so, separating out, like,
and aesthetics are a thing, you know?
I mean, they just are,
and people don't have the same interest in them.
And, you know, I'm curious
about, you know, when and how often people will use
a technology to do something
that can only exist on that technology
instead of being able to exist in another form.
Yeah, I mean, there's something very interesting
about the technology, but we're so early in this process
that it's hard to make sense of what should legitimately,
you know, command our attention
versus what's a bunch of bullshit.
I just see, like, a lot of nonsense,
and I see a lot of people losing money
'cause they're getting caught up in something
without fully understanding it, and now we're in the middle
of this crypto crash, you know.
I think that's gonna sort out a lot of this problem
and have people thinking differently about this,
but it's interesting to see so many things in flux
as a result of it, but I guess, if there is, you know,
something interesting about it, or worth saying about it,
it's that people are talking about art in a way
that maybe they weren't before all of this.
Yeah, I mean, art has always been,
it's always had its place in popular culture,
and often, it's about art and money.
You know, it's about, like, the Leonardo da Vinci
that sold for X number amount.
The auction, yeah.
500 or something crazy.
Yes, exactly.
$500 million, yeah.
Yep, and so,
that's often what it is.
I think that, in general, having people talk about art
is better than not having people talk about art,
and I think anything that people are trying
to learn about and expand their mind around
is good, you know?
So, for me,
I'm interested, as I said, in culture, right,
and so I'm interested in,
you know, I've had a Coinbase account, you know, a long time
'cause I wanted to see what it was like
to buy Bitcoin, you know?
I have a Wallet.
I uploaded my first NFT.
I learned about gas fees.
You know, I kept going back and checking.
You know, I was like, I'm not paying $400 for something
that's free, you know?
And then I'm like, well, who's getting that money,
and what does that mean, and what does mining mean?
So, I like learning things,
and so that's where I am on this, you know?
Right.
I'm curious about it.
I'm not invested.
But that has nothing
to do with art.
It has nothing
Yeah.
I think, at some point, an artist will do something
really interesting with this.
I just don't know that I've seen that yet.
Yeah, and you know, I mean,
I remember when there was, what were they calling it?
I can't even remember,
but it was basically like computer art,
you know, which was in the early aughts,
and it was like, okay, the next thing is gonna be this,
you know, computer art.
I just can't remember what it's called,
I mean, 'cause it's gone, right?
So, every 10 years, every 20 years, you know,
once a generation or whatever, like, this new thing comes on
and, you know, something stays,
but very little, you know?
Right.
Well, now it's about AI creating original pieces
of art.
Yeah,
that's not gonna happen.
Is that art?
No.
(Rich laughing loudly)
What if the AI intends it to be art,
is saying, "This is my art?"
Yeah, but the AI-
If you can infer consciousness in that AI,
would that make a difference?
Yes, it would,
but I can't, and I don't.
We're not there yet.
No.
I want to switch gears a little bit
and talk about leadership.
I mean, you're somebody who knows how to raise
a tremendous amount of money.
You're somebody, you talked earlier about execution,
like, you know follow-through,
you know how to execute on these ambitious goals,
get these buildings built, you know,
instill these programs that then, you know,
are impacting lots and lots of people,
you know how to lead teams.
I don't know that I would think of you
as, like, a business person,
but ostensibly you are, right?
So, what have you learned about business
and leadership and, you know, basically making good
on these goals and promises that you make?
Yeah, it's interesting.
I mean, I've been a CEO for, like, 15 years, you know,
and that was a learning for me also, is that, you know,
I realized I'm super entrepreneurial,
I have a super high tolerance for risk.
I run all of these kind of micro businesses
within this large umbrella,
and I have a clear leadership style,
I have a clear, you know, area of expertise,
you know, like my thing, right,
like trend identification and brand building for goods
and services aimed at high-net-worth individuals.
Like, that's what I do.
(Rich laughing)
That's like my pitch, I know.
I don't even know
what you just said.
You can unpack that
if you want.
Yeah.
You know, so,
I'm really good at finding talent, right?
That's why I'm good at picking artists,
so I'm also really great at building a team,
and the way that I-
You could've been an agent
for artists with that talent.
(Heidi sighs heavily)
I don't think so.
So, what I don't do, really,
is, I don't know, it's interesting.
I was gonna say, like,
like I don't sell things,
which I don't, but I do.
Like, I sell ideas, you know, I sell concepts, I sell,
I sell meaning, you know, I sell experiences.
And when you're raising money,
you have to sell these people
on an idea or that their money will be funneled
into something meaningful for them and for the world.
Yes.
Like, you're in marketing.
Yeah, part of it.
Yeah, I'm in a bunch of different things, you know?
I'm also in product development, you know?
I am also in,
yeah, learning systems-
Construction.
I'm also in construction
and development, you know?
(laughing) Yeah.
And, yeah, I'm also in, you know, retail,
so food service, you know, all these different things.
That's what's so interesting about a museum,
is that it is a non-for-profit, but it's a business,
and with all of these different verticals.
So, what I am really good at is finding the right people
and giving the sort of 30,000 foot view,
and then letting people execute.
So, it's sort of like a constellation
of a lot of different planets, you know,
coming together under the same umbrella.
And what are the lessons that you've learned
about how to lead teams of people or empower the people
that are, you know, working below you
and in cooperation with you?
Yeah, authentic leadership, for sure.
You know, telling people the why.
You know, everyone wants to know the why,
and so all these different things that I do,
they all intersect with each other.
So, it's like, I want to know the intentions of the artists.
I want people to know what my intention is,
like why am I asking you to do this?
Another thing is, like, everything matters.
Like, literally, everything matters, you know?
There are these, not everything matters the same, right?
You know, so like 20% of the things matter, you know,
like 100%, and 80% of the things matter, you know, like 20%,
and, you know, I mean, that doesn't add up,
but it kind of does.
The other thing I've learned is, like,
you've got to be courageous
and have the difficult conversations,
and that's what I mean when I say, like, everything matters,
like you can't let one thing go.
And one of the things that I say a lot is that, you know,
like, I'm not a lawyer, like, I'm not an accountant.
I don't have any special skills.
You know, all that I have, really, is my integrity,
and, you know, that's what I have to defend,
you know, at all costs.
And so,
I wake up
most days
and people want me to do something or say something,
you know, and it's often not in alignment
with, you know, what I know is right.
And so, you know,
not flinching from having those difficult conversations,
and doing it diplomatically, of course,
allowing other people to have wins, you know,
not needing to be right,
those are some of the things.
I would imagine
all of those skills
are enhanced by meditation, right,
finding that moment of pause,
where you can process how to best respond versus react,
how to be tactful in your communication,
all of those things.
Do you have a sense of what your leadership was like
prior to meditation versus now?
Yes, I was a yeller.
Yeah. (laughs)
You know, and that's,
you know, (sighs heavily) I had,
I had these charms made, and I wore 'em around my neck,
and one was like two stick figures, like a boy and a girl,
and had the initials of my kids, E and O,
and then I had another one made,
and it said, "Be graceful, yelling doesn't work."
And that's what I had before I started meditating,
and I would kind of, you know, rub it,
and that's what I learned, because it's terrible, you know?
Yeah.
And that is, like, I can't ever imagine now yelling.
I mean, and how horrible, like, to yell,
like at my kids or, you know,
at my team or, you know, like a random person, you know?
I mean, how awful.
What is the modality of meditation that you practice?
I do different things.
Sometimes it's silent, and sometimes it's guided.
Recently, I've been doing a lot of guided meditations
because my mind is pretty active.
At different points, I've been able to do silent meditation,
but now it's often guided.
I am a huge fan-
Like on a particular app?
Yeah, a huge fan of Insight Timer,
and it keeps track of my days and my minutes and my hours,
and there are certain practitioners
on there that I really like.
I like this woman, Sarah Blondin,
and there's one particular meditation that she has.
It's maybe 12 minutes long,
and it's called "Learning To Surrender",
and I listened to it on my way here today, you know,
when it took me longer than I had anticipated,
and, you know, it's like, I can't be reminded
too many times to surrender.
Yeah.
What is the ambition
for the museum?
Like, if you have your druthers
and everything goes your way,
and it's five years down the road
and you're looking back,
what is it that you hope to accomplish or express?
I want people to feel welcome, you know,
and it gets back to this idea that I talked about earlier,
that, you know, like, I know for myself,
and I use myself as a metric, you know,
like if I don't care about it, why should I, you know,
want anyone else to care about it or hope that they will.
And I know for myself, like,
what I wanted most in my life, and now,
which I have so much gratitude that I actually have,
is, you know, I wanted to feel seen and loved,
you know, and so much so that I put it in my phone
and my calendar every morning at 7:00 a.m.,
and it still buzzes, you know?
7:00 a.m. Pacific, every morning,
it says, "I feel seen and loved," and I put it in there,
and when I put it in, I didn't.
I didn't feel seen and I didn't feel loved,
and, you know, I manifested it,
and so that's what I want.
That's what I use my platform for,
and that's what art, for me, is a vehicle for,
is to have people feel that they're seen
and feel that they're loved.
Yeah, well,
I have this sense that all of these many artists
that you've known and that you chronicle
in the books and on the podcast
see you and respect you and revere you.
I know they think incredibly highly of you,
and you commandeer, like, a level of respect
because of that integrity that's so important to you,
which I think is really cool.
As you said, like, all you have is your reputation
and your integrity, and for this creative community
of, like, brilliant artists all out there,
who speak so highly of you and think so highly of you,
it has to be, I mean, that is the fulfillment
of that 7:00 a.m., like, you know,
little thing that you get to see every day.
Yeah, you know.
You know, I heard this thing some years ago
about, like, compound interest, you know,
and it was like about retirement, you know,
and it's like, if you don't start saving in your 20s,
like, you can never catch up, right?
That really stuck with me and, you know,
I really don't drink, you know,
I have a mostly vegan, you know, diet.
You know, I just, I make these kind of hard choices, right,
and part of it is because,
like, I'm thinking about the future.
And so, I'm living in the present,
but I know that like, all, of these years,
you know, of meditating
and, like, standing up for what I believe in
and defending people's rights
to show the art that they want to show
and having the difficult conversations, you know, like,
that's like in my, like, the bank of my soul.
Right, yeah, you're making deposits
in the integrity bank account,
the karma bank account, right?
Yeah.
That's been compounding interest all these years.
Yeah, it's cool.
Well, the last thing I want to ask you before we wrap it up
is, you know, it's kind of hearkening back
to what we were talking about at the beginning
of the conversation, but just, like,
for somebody who's listening to this,
who is still grappling with this idea of, like,
should I care about this, like I just want to, like,
leave people with like a little spark of inspiration
to get them in the door or get them thinking about art
in a way that maybe historically they haven't.
Yeah, I mean, what I would say is like,
what have you got to lose, you know?
Like, why not try it, you know?
One of the things we say at the museum is like,
if you don't like what you see, come back again,
you know, 'cause it's gonna be different,
like it's gonna be different,
and you're gonna be different, you know?
I did this show in Aspen,
it was called "Zombies: Pay Attention!",
and it was inspired by this Bruce Nauman work,
which is one of my favorite works of art of all time,
and I may have talked to you about it before,
but it's writing in reverse, as if it's like in a mirror.
I don't know if I can swear,
you know, or not, but it says-
Yeah, you can swear.
It says, "Pay attention, motherfuckers," you know,
and, like, that was kind of my mantra for a long time.
It's like, "Pay attention, motherfuckers," you know,
like, you only have one life,
like this moment, (clicks fingers) gone,
this moment, (clicks fingers) gone,
this moment, (clicks fingers) gone, you know?
So, it's like, what do you want to do?
Like, what are you here to do?
And Rand Stagen said to me, like,
"You're doing the world a great disservice
by playing small."
So, like, why not look at art?
Why not try it?
I think that's a great place to end it.
That is, I'm inspired now.
(Heidi laughing)
That worked.
I love what you do, and I love this person
that you've become.
It's been cool to watch you from the sidelines, like,
mature into this role that you've clearly earned,
and I just, I salute you, I'm at your service,
and I think it's great, Heidi.
So, I appreciate you coming and sharing with me today.
I wish you well as we near the opening.
It's gonna be a big moment for you,
and in the meantime, everybody should pick up
"Conversations with Artists III".
Is it still only available
on the OCMA website?
Yeah, you inspired me,
you know, with your book, and not having it on Amazon,
and I was like, why not drive traffic to the OCMA website?
Yeah.
You know, I mean, honestly,
the website's not very great yet,
but it'll get better as we get closer-
Well, now you have to click Popup to find the book.
It should at least say "Book"
or something, you know, to make it
a little easier for people.
We'll address that, yes.
(both laughing)
Yeah, so it's ocma.net?
Art.
Oh, .art, and then click Popup.
You'll find the book there.
Yes.
If you're in Orange County, the museum opens October.
Do you have a set date?
Yes, we do,
and I'd actually like to invite everyone
who's listening to come.
Cool.
So, October 8th, 5:00 p.m., 24-hour opening.
So, October 8th, 5:00 p.m.,
to October 9th, 5:00 p.m.
Open all night?
Open all night.
Oh, wow.
Sunrise yoga,
movies for insomniacs,
tours of the exhibitions with past curators, directors,
silent dance party, you know, music, like,
a ceremony to kick it off.
That sounds pretty cool.
Something to close.
That sounds like
a pretty groovy opening.
Yeah.
Yeah, right on.
It's gonna be amazing,
and everyone's welcome.
Awesome.
And totally free.
Until then, you can also listen to Heidi's podcast,
"Conversations About Art",
which you can find on all the podcast platforms.
Anywhere else you want to direct people?
I think that's it.
You think that's good?
Yeah.
All right, how do you feel?
You feel okay?
I feel great.
We did it.
Yeah.
It was cool.
Yeah, I feel like we could,
you know, do version two and three and four.
Absolutely, absolutely.
So, yeah,
lots to talk about.
Yeah, right on.
All right, I love you, Heidi, thank you.
To be continued.
Thank you so much.
Peace.
(whispers) Play it.
(slow music)
(projector reel whirring)